STEVE: SO MUCH BAD NEWS THESE
DAYS WE’RE BACK WITH SOME GOOD
NEWS AND IT’S A FOX NEWS ALERT.
TWO BIG JOBS REPORTS JUST
RELEASED MOMENTS AGO, LET’S SEE
NINE MINUTES AGO.
4.8 MILLION JOBS WERE ADDED IN
JUNE.
ECONOMISTS HAD PREDICTED AROUND
MAYBE 3 MILLION AS YOU CAN SEE
THAT IS A GIGANTIC BLOWOUT
NUMBER AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: THAT’S RIGHT THE
NATIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
DROPPING FROM 13.3% IN MAY TO
11.1%, BRIAN.
BRIAN:  THE WEEKLY JOBLESS
CLAIMS REPORT ALSO OUT JUST OVER
1.4 MILLION AMERICANS FILING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT LAST WEEK.
THAT’S A LITTLE HIGHER THAN WHAT
SOME ECONOMISTS PREDICTED.
MORE THAN 48 MILLION AMERICANS
HAVE FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
SINCE THE START OF THE PANDEMIC.
LET’S BRING IN SENATOR FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, FIRST OFF YOUR TAKE ON
THIS AND WHAT IT MEANS FOR
ANOTHER RESCUE PACKAGE JUST
ON FIRST TAKE?
>> WELL IT MEANS WE NEED A
RESCUE PACKAGE THAT WOULD HIT
THE GAS AND MAKE THE ECONOMY
GROW FASTER.
THIS IS REALLY GOOD NEWS.
IT MEANS AMERICA’S COMING BACK
ECONOMICALLY.
PEOPLE ARE GOING BACK TO WORK.
THERE’S CONFIDENCE THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY OPEN UP THE COUNTRY, SO
THE PRESIDENT IS PROPOSING A
PAYROLL TAX CUT THAT WOULD PUT
MONEY INTO THE POCKET OF
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES.
THAT WOULD STIMULATE THE ECONOMY
AND AN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL TO
GIVE AMERICA A FACE LIFT WITH
OUR ROAD, BRIDGES AND PORTS THAT
WOULD SET IN MOTION FUTURE JOB
CREATION.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE YOU DON’T
PAY PEOPLE MORE IN UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THAN THEY GET TO WORK
THAT WILL HELP GET PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK.
I’M EVEN WILLING TO DO A MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASE.
THERE’S SO MANY THINGS,
LIABILITY REFORMS, SO YOU CAN
OPEN UP WITHOUT BEING SUED,
CONGRESS NEEDS TO ACT IN JULY TO
CONTINUE THIS TREND.
IF WE HAD THE RIGHT KIND OF
STIMULUS PACKAGE WE BE GOING
THROUGH THE ROOF BY OCTOBER IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC GROWTH.
AINSLEY: I KNOW YOU ARE ALL
TAKING A TWO WEEK BREAK WHEN ARE
YOU ALL BACK AND WHEN DO YOU
THINK THIS NEXT RELIEF PACKAGE
WILL BE RELEASED?
>> JUST AS SOON AS WE GET THAT
WE NEED TO GET UP AND GET THIS
DONE.
BOTTOM LINE HERE, THE BOTTOM
LINE HERE IS WE GOT AN OPENING,
TAKE IT.
IT MAY NOT LAST.
NOW THE CORONAVIRUS CAN BE A WET
BLANKET IN ALL OF THIS REOPENING
IF WE DON’T CONTROL IT, SO
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEEDS TO GET ON
THE PHONE AND CALL ALL THE
GOVERNORS.
WHAT CAN I DO TO HELP YOU?
WHAT DO YOU NEED THAT YOU DON’T
HAVE?
LET’S REALLY DOUBLE DOWN ON
TESTING BECAUSE THAT GIVES US
INSIGHT HOW TO CONTROL THE VIRUS
AND A VACCINE AND THERAPIES ARE
ON THE WAY.
I’M INCREASINGLY OPTIMISTIC THAT
WE’RE GOING TO CONTROL THE VIRUS
AND REOPEN THE ECONOMY SMARTLY.
STEVE: AND THAT’S REALLY THE KEY
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH THE NUMBERS
ARE GOING UP, YOU KNOW, WE’RE
APPROACHING 50,000 NEW CASES
YESTERDAY, WE’RE FIGURING OUT
HOW TO MANAGE IT AND WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND MASKS AND
PHARMACEUTICALS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
AND YOU THINK YOU KNOW, WE
SHUTDOWN THE WHOLE WORLD FOR THE
MOST PART FOR ABOUT 100
DAYS, DID WE EVER DO IT ON THAT
OR  WAS THAT JUST PART OF THE
LEARNING CURVE BECAUSE IN
THE BEGINNING WE DON’T KNOW
WHERE THAT WAS GOING.
>> I HEAR A LOT OF CHATTER ON
CABLE TV I NEED TO WATCH LESS OF
IT.
STEVE: YOU’RE ONE OF THE CHATTER
ERS SIR.
>> HERE IS THE DEAL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TOLD IF YOU
DO NOTHING AND LET THE MENTALITY
TAKE OVER YOU’RE GOING TO LOSE
2 MILLION AMERICANS.
WE’RE GOING TO PROBABLY HAVE
180,000 DEAD AFTER HAVING SHUT
THE WHOLE WORLD DOWN SO I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S DECISION TO
SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMY AND FOCUS
ON PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT COMING
BACK TO AMERICA, VACCINES AND
THERAPIES AND TESTING SAVED
PROBABLY A COUPLE MILLION PEOPLE
’S LIVES.
IF YOU DON’T THINK THIS IS
DEADLY BY NOW WHAT WOULD IT TAKE
TO CONVINCE YOU THIS VIRUS IS
DEADLY.
BRIAN:  LET’S SWITCH TO RUSSIA.
BETH SANNER IS THE PRESIDENT’S
BRIEFER AND DID NOT VERBALLY
BRIEF THE PRESIDENT ON THE
THREAT OF THE RUSSIANS IF
THE FACT IS PROVEN CORRECT, THE
RUSSIANS GIVING THE TALIBAN
MONEY TO KILL AMERICANS.
NOW SETH MOLTEN SAYS FROM WHAT
HE KNOWS THE PRESIDENT COMMITTED
TREASON.
WHERE DOES LINDSEY GRAHAM STAND?
>> WELL I DON’T KNOW IF
CONGRESSMAN MOLTEN HAS BEEN
BRIEFED BUT I’D SAY I’M A FAIRLY
HAWKISH GUY, WOULD YOU AGREE
WITH THAT?
WELLS FARGO YES.
>> RUSSIA HAS BEEN UP TO NO
GOOD IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PLACES AND I HAVEN’T HAD A LOT
OF AFFECTION FOR PUTIN’S RUSSIA
BUT I DO UNDERSTAND THE MILITARY
I THINK THE SYSTEM GOT IT RIGHT.
YOU HAD CONTRADICTORY
INTELLIGENCE, WE INCREASED FORCE
PROTECTION JUST TO BE CAUTIOUS
BUT I CAN’T IMAGINE BRIEFING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES ABOUT THIS ALLEGATION
GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE
INDEPENDENCE.
NOW WHERE WERE ALL OF THESE
DEMOCRATS WHEN BENGHAZI WAS ON
FIRE, WHEN THEY WERE CALLING FOR
HELP FROM THE CONSOLATE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OBAMA WAS BRIEFED AND
WENT TO BED AND NEVER CALLED
ANYBODY FOR A DAY AND A HALF
WHILE OUR PEOPLE WERE BEING
SLAUGHTERED IN BENGHAZI.
WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE THEN?
THE INTELLIGENCE HERE IN MY VIEW
DOES NOT JUSTIFY A NATION STATE
CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA.
STEVE: YEAH, WELL YOU WERE
BRIEFED THOUGH, RIGHT?
>> YES I WAS BRIEFED AND I
ASKED A LOT OF HARD QUESTIONS
AND YOU DON’T TELL THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES EVERYTHING
YOU WOULD TELL A SECOND
LIEUTENANT.
STEVE: EXACTLY.
SENATOR GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THE BRIEFER AND ALL OF THAT
OTHER STUFF AS WELL, IT
SHOULDN’T SURPRISE ANYBODY THAT
IT’S A BIG STORY IN THE NEW YORK
TIMES.
I MEAN, THAT’S WHAT THEY DO.
THEY COME UP WITH THESE BIG
STORIES TO MAKE DONALD TRUMP
LOOK BAD.
>> AND IT’S ALL BS.
HE WASN’T BRIEFED AND THERE WAS
NO CONSENSUS, AS A MATTER OF
FACT THE MOST RELIABLE FORM OF
INTELLIGENCE GATHERED AROUND
THIS EPISODE WAS AGAINST RUSSIA
GIVING MONEY TO THE TALIBAN.
THE IRANIANS ARE GIVING MONEY TO
THE TALIBAN.
RUSSIA HAS BEEN GIVING WEAPONS
TO THE TALIBAN.
THE POINT IS THAT THIS PRESIDENT
AND I DISAGREE WITH HIM
SOMETIMES ABOUT MILITARY
FOOTPRINTS OVER THERE TO PROTECT
US HERE BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
AMERICAN PERSONNEL ON THE GROUND
IN HARMS WAY, THIS PRESIDENT HAS
AN UNWAVERING DESIRE AND
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT OUR TROOPS
ON THE GROUND.
IF YOU DON’T BELIEVE ME, ASK THE
RUSSIAN MERCINARIES KILLED IN
SYRIA WHEN THEY THREATENED OUR
TROOPS.
BRIAN:  YEAH THEY WERE WIPED OUT
REAL QUICK, KARL ROVE WROTE AN
EDITORIAL SAYING THE
PRESIDENT HAS TO RESET IN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS OR  HE’S
GOING TO LOSE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT HAS
TO RESET HIS RE-ELECTION?
>> YEAH, I THINK HE’S GOT TO GO
ON THE OFFENSE.
I DON’T KNOW IF HE WILL LOSE OR
NOT BUT A HELL OF A STORY TO
TELL HE SHOULD START TELLING IT.
YOU WANT TO BRING BACK
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY FROM CHINA I’VE GOT
A BILL THAT GIVES A TAX CREDIT
TO MAKE PPE HERE AND TREATING IT
LIKE MILITARY UNIFORMS SO
NATIONAL SECURITY HAS THAT AND
CHINA LIED AND AMERICANS DIED.
LET AMERICAN CITIZENS SUE THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY, DO
AN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
YOU GO ON THE OFFENSE MR.
PRESIDENT AND YOUR SECOND
TERM WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
FINISH THE JOB OF YOUR FIRST
TERM KEEP BUILDING THE WALL FIX
THE BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM,
MORE JUDGES.
MAKE SURE IRAN NEVER GETS A
NUCLEAR WEAPON.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT
ON ALL THESE ISSUES HE’S FOR LAW
AND ORDER AND JOE BIDEN IS BEING
CONTROLLED BY THE MOST RADICAL
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THIS ELECTION IS STILL DONALD
TRUMP’S TO LOSE BUT PROSECUTE
THE CASE, MR. PRESIDENT.
STEVE: SENATOR GRAHAM BEFORE YOU
GO, I SAW YOU PLAYED GOLF WITH
THE PRESIDENT OVER THE WEEKEND.
WHO WON?
>> I’VE NEVER SEEN HIM PLAY
THIS WELL.
I MEAN, HE’S GOT MORE ON HIS
SHOULDERS I’M HOPING HE’S A
LITTLE DISTRACTED, HE BEAT ME
LIKE A DRUM.
IT WAS AMAZING HE SHOT A 74.
BRIAN:  ALWAYS LOSE TO THE BOSS.
>> I’M NOT JOKING.
IF I COULD BEAT HIM I WOULD.
AINSLEY: SENATOR, OUR THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS DEALING WITH COVID
THERE SO THANKS SO MUCH FOR WHAT